this video is sponsored by movie go to
movie comm slash Thomas flight for your
extended free trial so maybe you
suddenly have a bunch of extra time at
home for some reason I don't know why
that would be but maybe you're asking
yourself what do i watch over the coming
days weeks or months maybe you'll
finally get around to watching the wire
got this America my my current personal
project is to finally finish The
Sopranos although I've been a little
distracted by Tiger King but I want to
make some recommendations that might
help you make the most of your viewing
time while you're stuck at home this
video is not going to be a list of
pandemic or disaster movies although I
have been thinking about HBO's Chernobyl
a lot recently
what is the December to say three point
six wrong but that's as high as the mean
to three point six terrible sure if
you're not freaked out enough already
you could definitely check out contagion
or the Andromeda Strain
but that's not what this video is about
this also isn't going to be a list of
movies that I like and think you should
watch if you're someone who wants to
learn more about film and if you're
watching this channel I assume you are
what I'm going to recommend is that you
create a watching project for yourself I
think focusing on viewing a smaller
section of film continue a lot about the
medium I want to encourage you to give
yourself a small watching project that
you can actually complete while you're
at home for a few weeks or months
completing it will give you a sense of
accomplishment and you'll have learned
something along the way but what do I
mean by a watching project well for
example you could watch all of directors
films from start to finish this is
fairly easy with some directors like
Terrence Malick Wes Anderson Stanley
Kubrick or Paul Thomas Anderson if you
do this with Wes Anderson you'll get to
see his style emerge and become more
complex over the course of his nine
films if you do this with Paul Thomas I
understand you'll get to see his
incredible range how his work is
powerful when he's doing a massive
melodramatic and sümbül piece you
understand there's no one else and how
it's also powerful even when he's doing
a quieter much more subtle and
understated character piece
a Welsh rabbit you can choose whichever
director intrigues you if there's one
you really like that you've only seen
one or two films by make it a goal to
watch the rest of that directors
filmography although I will say there
are some directors that are a much more
ambitious project than others another
project you could tackle is to explore
the films of a specific country
parasites recent popularity has
interested a lot of people in what
Korean film has to offer but if you've
never taken the time to explore Japanese
film French Russian Italian and many
others there's a lot to see out there
obviously you can't watch all the films
from my country so I recommend narrowing
things down by looking up the top
directors from the country and choosing
a few films from each director to check
out for example if you want to explore
Japanese cinema you could check out some
of the films by Akira Kurosawa
[Music]
Oh soo Miyazaki and Takeshi Kitano if
you want to explore Korean cinema you
could start by watching some more bong
joon-ho and then check out chan wook
Park and Chang Don Lee and expand from
there I love doing this because it
scratches a similar itch that traveling
does for me
granted to a much lesser degree but when
you immerse yourself in a country's
films you can start to get a sense of
the culture and the language it's not
just a way to learn about film but a way
to learn about the world instead of
travelling around the world you could
travel in time it's easy to watch mostly
contemporary films or just the cream of
the crop from the past but why not pick
a year and explore that year cinema you
could check out 1939 often proclaims the
greatest year in American film it has
such classics as The Wizard of Oz
stagecoach watering Heights mr. Smith
goes to Washington and many others or
maybe check out the year you were born
and watch the top films or Best Picture
nominees from that year this gives you a
sense of the trends at a specific time
in film but also a small snapshot of
part of the culture at that time finally
you could explore a smaller genre a film
or a film movement you could go for a
more famous one like the French New Wave
if you haven't checked it out yet just
start with some truth or you could try
the film Noirs of the 40s and 50s you're
a friend of mine but when a man for the
Homicide Squad just drops in at 2
o'clock in the morning I kind of its
fooling around which you could expand
into a larger project if you followed
the thread forward into the present
watching the genre develop as it becomes
neo-noir or you could go for something a
little more obscure like the recent
Greek weird wave many people have seen
the lobster seems like no sure you like
oh yeah did you know the lobsters
strange style is part of a larger
stylistic movement in Greek cinema you
can start by moving backwards to your
ghost lanthum OSes earlier films like
dog tooth and then branch out to films
like pity or Attenberg
although fair warning if you're gonna
explore Greek weird wave all these films
are definitely really weird you have a
ton of options here from the silent era
movements of German Expressionism and
French Impressionism to Italian
Neorealism American New Wave anybody
across more recent and contemporary
movements like Dogma 95 or mumblecore
hey you don't want to thank you guys I
want to plant a gel brought this pizza
you know and then we get to share this
this is cool
seriously yeah we're happy to be here
man you are so sweet I'm so happy to
meet you my suggestion is to find
something that sounds interesting to you
and then do a little research and make a
list of films to watch from that
movement people often ask me if I've
gone to film school or what kind of
training I have to make these videos
education I studied reading and spelling
and the truth is I have no formal
training in film analysis I've been a
full-time editor for years and I've
worked on video production and film sets
but the greatest education I think you
can get in film analysis and criticism
is watching films and crafting a project
like one of these for yourself to focus
on a single subject time place or
directors work can be a fantastic way to
educate yourself it allows you to see
how trends and techniques develop and
how styles can form across an individual
creator or entire country's work this
video is brought to you by mu B movie is
an online cinema streaming and download
service they have a hand curated library
and one of the things I love about MU B
is that sometimes they'll focus on
things like a smaller film movement
it's how I discovered Greek weird wave
and the movie pity if you're sitting at
home wondering what to watch and you
want somebody to help you find something
movie can be a great way to discover
stuff so give it a try today you can get
your extended free trial when you go to
movie comm slash Thomas flight that's M
ubi comm slash Thomas flight or click
the link in the description for your
extended free trial thanks so much for
watching I hope all of you are doing
well
staying safe in this crazy time I want
to thank my patrons at patreon.com slash
Thomas Flay their support helps me
continue to make videos
[Music]